dann war gerade auch noch FDP Parteitag
oder wie ältere heute show Autoren sagen
halbe Sendung schon voll
und diesmal muss man sagen was ja
besonders spannend weil die Liberalen ja
so hadern mit der Ampel mittendrin aber
irgendwie dagegen man könnte auch sagen
viele von denen haben jetzt eine
gespaltene Persönlichkeit das ist ja so
und das beste Beispiel ist Robert
habecks Gebäude Energiegesetz sie wissen
schon die leidige Sache mit den Heizung
im Grundsatz hat die FDP Roberts Ideen
zwar schon im ampelvertrag mit abgelegt
im Koalitionsausschuss neulich im
Kabinett aber deswegen kann man die ja
trotzdem total doof finden das
heizungsverbotsgesetz von Robert Habeck
Unsinn
hat Robert Habeck ein Problem dass ihr
Haus wegen Robert Harbeck wie ein
Damokles Schwert über ihnen hängt Robert
habe Robert habe Weg Robert Habeck hat
schon viele erste Ministerium an die
Öffentlichkeit geben lassen aber diese
Stück ist einfach unerträglich für uns
soweit vielen Dank ich bin wieder meine
Liebe
ja mach das mal warum sieht die FDP den
Habeck nicht einfach als dorning
Geschosse eigentlich geht es ja nur um
neue Heizung also die alten Öl und Gas
Schätzchen können weiterlaufen bis sie
zerfallen aber die Menschen haben
trotzdem Angst vor harbecks heizhammer
ja so nennt die Bild das jetzt immer
harbecks heizhammer und diese Ängste
werden fleißig gemolken von der FDP das
kann man von der Regierungspartei
irgendwie unkollegial finden oder
erpresserisch gegenüber den Grünen man
kann aber auch sagen ja wenn die Grünen
auf unsere Vorschläge in dieser Frage
eingehen dann ist natürlich eine
Zusammenarbeit durchaus möglich
ja ist doch ganz einfach die Grünen
müssen einfach exakt das machen was wir
Ihnen sagen dann können wir Freunde
bleiben ja das war Frank Scheffler
Anführer der sogenannten FDP
heizrebellen Schäffler nennt harbecks
gesetzt das natürlich noch Schwächen hat
eine
Atombombe für unser Land ja kleiner hat
das nicht ja Atombombe Frank Schäffler
der übrigens 2014 mal im Handelsblatt
geschrieben hat und ich zitiere ich
bekenne hiermit ich bin ein Klima
Skeptiker und wird es dennoch ein
bisschen wärmer dann freue ich mich über
bessere Ernteerträge und den besseren
Wein
ja den trinkt er offensichtlich gerne
sage ich mal
aber grundsätzlich ist ganz wichtig
grundsätzlich ist die FDP schon total
für Klimaschutz also keine
Klimaskeptiker sind für Klimaschutz das
heißt bei denen nur anders
technologieoffenheit ja
technologieoffenheit also offen für
e-fuels Kernfusion das Beamen solche
Sachen eben ne also gut in Wirklichkeit
wissen die natürlich ganz genau dass
e-fuels auch in Zukunft viel zu teuer
und viel zu ineffizient sein werden es
geht ausschließlich darum dass
verbrennerverbot zu verhindern oder
mindestens lange zu verzögern
technologieoffenheit ist FDP sprech für
weiter so mit Öl und Gas gut auf der
anderen Seite wie muss das für die sein
stellen sich das doch mal eine Sekunde
vor
unschuldig gezwungen zum Regieren mit
grünen und Socken
du fühlst dich ausgelaugt weil du die
Arbeit deiner eigenen Regierung blöd
findest du leidest an der
Unvereinbarkeit von Regierung und
Opposition dann Buch jetzt den Sommer im
Wellness Retreat Club los liberalos auf
Ibiza gönn dir intensive heizölmassagen
unbehelligt von nervigen Grünen oder
unsere berühmte 6 Zylinder Boxermotor
Meditation
und relax mit Freunden beim abendlichen
Bogenschießen auf beschissene
Wärmepumpen Club los liberalos Zeit nur
für dich und vor allem ohne Robert
Habeck
[Applaus]
ja einfach mal die geschundene liberale
Seele baumeln lassen so aber wissen Sie
eigentlich was mich am allermeisten
aufregt auf diesem FDP Parteitag wurde
ernsthaft gefordert ARD und ZDF
zusammenzulegen ey liberale schon mal
was von Leistungsprinzip gehört wir vom
ZDF sind seit Jahren Marktführer das
haben wir uns harte arbeitet und jetzt
wollen wir uns zwangsvereinigen mit
diesen los mit der ARD
also wirklich jetzt gibt's doch gar
nicht dann lieber mit RTL2 oder Beate
Uhse TV
und damit nicht genug die Liberalen
wollen uns die Unterhaltung verbieten
bitte ach die wollen nur Florian
Silbereisen verbieten
aber die Frage ist doch sind
Musikformate mit Florian Silbereisen und
Co sind die etwas was nur der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk machen
kann nein das können Privatsender auch
wollen die aber nicht weil scheiße ist
nein völlig unnötig Applaus an dieser
Zeit nein also bitte man muss dazu sagen
der Silbereisen ist tierisch erfolgreich
jetzt nicht so erfolgreich wie Giovanni
Zarrella ich meine das geht ja gar nicht
das geht ja gar nicht so ich sag mal die
FDP soll endlich vor der eigenen Tür
kehren und sich zum Beispiel fragen
warum bei denen immer noch so wenig
Frauen mitmachen ja ganz wenig Frauen
das frische unverbrauchte Gesicht der
Partei ist ja eher Wolfgang Kubicki ja
ist ja so ja
gibt alle drei Minuten Interviews mit
eingebauter Shitstorm Garantie klebt
aber am vizeposten
80% Männer in dieser Partei ich sage
Ihnen es gibt inzwischen
männergesangsvereine die haben einen
höheren Frauenanteil als die FDP
gut gestern war der sogenannte Girls Day
da haben die Liberalen auf Jobmessen
wenigstens mal versucht weibliche
Nachwuchs zu ködern und überall gab es
Regen ist Interesse zum Beispiel für den
spannenden Job des tatortreinigers das
ist echt das Blut genauso nebenan wo der
alt er würdige Beruf des Kükens
vorgestellt wurde
nur am Stand mit dem FDP-Politiker war
wieder gar nichts los hey Bock auf
liberale Politik
oh ja ich meine klar gibt's auch gute
Ideen in der FDP ist doch logisch aber
manches wirkt eben auch sehr dogmatisch
zum Beispiel die Weigerung über jede Art
von Steuererhöhung auch nur zu reden ja
ich weiß das gehört zur Liberalen DNA
das haben wir alle verstanden aber ja
aber warum kann man nicht wenigstens
bestimmte Subventionen streichen wie die
für Diesel oder das idiotische
Dienstwagen Privileg das hat immerhin
die Vorsitzende Wirtschaftsweisen
neulich gefordert geht aber nicht sagt
Lindner weil auch das wäre ja eine
verkappte Steuererhöhung unbelehrbar der
Mann
neunte Stunde Nachsitzen bei Frau Flagge
heute gerechte Besteuerung
der Christian unser kleiner rententer
Steuerreform Verweigerer willkommen
zurück
da sitzt er wieder und denkt er weiß
schon alles find sich richtig gut ne ja
es kommt auch so rüber so jetzt pass mal
auf Freundchen zum tausendsten Mal ja
die Steuerlast in Deutschland ist schon
sehr hoch und das bestreitet auch gar
keiner aber sie ist ungerecht verteilt
deswegen könnte man zum Beispiel den
Spitzensteuersatz später greifen lassen
nicht schon wie jetzt ab 63.000 im Jahr
ihn dafür aber erhöhen
hörst du zu ja das Gesicht wieder auf
Standby geschaltet
dann rate doch mal wer das mit dem
höheren Spitzensteuersatz gerade
vorgeschlagen hat dieser gefürchtete
Sozialist Fritze märz also seine CDU ist
neuerdings dafür und für eine flatex in
der Erbschaftssteuer 10% für alle ohne
Ausreden aber das fordern topökonom seit
Jahren nur du hältst wieder die ganze
Klasse auf okay
wenn ich ein Einfamilienhaus Erbe zahle
ich ganz normal Erbschaftssteuer er mich
aber mehr als 300 Wohnung stellt sich
automatisch als Wohnungsunternehmen und
bin Steuer begünstigt wenn wir
wenigstens diese schreiende
Ungerechtigkeit mal ändern würden wäre
das nicht schön
was wäre wenn Fragen möchte ich nicht
und kann ich auch nicht beantworten da
haben sie gewiss Verständnis dafür
ja ich merke schon wieder wie mein
Burnout anklopft
der deutsche Staat belastet Arbeit viel
zu stark und Vermögen und sehr hohe
Einkommen zu wenig und dann wundern wir
uns dass zwei Familien Kühne und Nagel
und die all die Erben mehr besitzen als
die komplette untere Hälfte der
Bevölkerung das ist doch Wahnsinn
und das hat keinen Zweck mit dir deine
Mutter kann nicht abholen los so wen
haben wir jetzt da
natürlich der Wolfgang unser fdp-problem
wäre deswegen diesmal
was ernsthaft Robert Habeck mit Putin
vergleichen warum Wolfgang warum weil
ich es will es
reicht du schreibst jetzt 100 mal an die
Tafel ich darf niemanden
nicht mal
na ja genau ja die Zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
Symbole hier bei uns im neuen Studio
gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten